here we go again into the looking glass
[Music]
innovating within the bounds of horrors
familiar tropes and rules is a difficult
task but one that the evil within two
handles with grace developer tango
GameWorks cleverly introduces old-school
horror design within the confines of a
semi-open world that ultimately makes
for an engaging trip into a world of
nightmares
[Applause]
picking up several years after the first
game we find the former detective
Sebastian Castellanos in dire straits
still wracked with guilt over the loss
of his family and haunted by his last
visit into the stem nightmare reality
when a shadowy organization gives him
the chance to set things right with his
past and rescue his daughter from the
dangerous and unstable world of Union he
willingly re-enters the Nightmare Realm
despite his residual trauma as Sebastian
wanders the many locations in Union
there's a general sense of deja vu
despite being one of the few survivors
from the first game oddly finds himself
falling for the same tricks and setups
at the world and its inhabitants layout
for him while this could be chalked up
as a simple retread much of these
instances make a point of illustrating
some key differences from this game and
the last feeling more like a sketch of a
hardened and weary protagonist in the
first game
Sebastian feels more realized and
grounded in the sequel giving a certain
gravitas to a struggle but he got away
and he's gotten Lily she must be so
scared alone I've got to find her before
he does something terrible to her
showing bewilderment and confusion
throughout the first game he's now more
confident and determined even throwing
in some fitting one-liners at the right
moments the supporting cast of villains
feel more active in the ongoing events
and have a greater sense of place this
time around
particularly with the eccentric serial
killer artist who photographs his
victims upon their death while there's
occasional moments of cheese and humour
throughout the Lebanon never feels out
of place which is an accomplishment
considering the game's pervasive McCobb
atmosphere there are a few notable
sections where backtracking is required
which slows the pacing and sense of
progression to a crawl despite this the
exploration is consistently enjoyable
and interesting showing a clear respect
for the evil with ends world the many
nods to the original game feel more
impactful for it giving a sense of
renewed appreciation for Sebastian's
previous adventure putting a greater
emphasis on the survival aspect of
survival horror the evil within two
places large attention to resource
management and braving the dangers in a
relatively spacious world
while common enemies are in fewer
numbers compared to the original game
therefore more threatening alone and can
easily manhandle sebastian there's a
thoughtful approach to engagement in
progression this time around which means
you let the thing twice about whether or
not to engage a group of enemies
compared to its predecessors singular
levels and unique chapters the evil
within two possesses a more organic and
interconnected set of places to explore
focusing on several large maps with
multiple points of interest over time
Union grows unstable turning a small
town into a horrifying and unnerving
shell of its former self streets
vertically upend and fire and blood
exude from places they shouldn't the
visual design of the evil within to
successfully juxtaposes vastly different
settings and aesthetics and presents
them in a bizarre package that
illustrates the erratic and
unpredictable nature of the world
throughout his journey sebastian carries
a communication device allowing him to
keep track of main objectives along with
points of interest and intel on the face
of side characters in the area how you
go about dealing with these characters
and exploring is up to you the evil
within accommodates those that prefer
action as much as those that like to be
stealthy combat is robust thanks to
improved weapon handling and character
upgrading that allows you to focus on
the specific areas of sebastian skill
set to enhance stealth combat and
agility expanding upon the originals
limited crafting with a more
comprehensive system sebastian can
scavenge supplies and other materials to
make ammo and health items while this
may seem like it can make things easy
efficient crafting can only be done at
dedicated workbenches whereas crafting
in the field should be done as a last
resort as it cost twice as many
materials this crafting element adds a
bit of a survivalist feel to the evil
within to where you're scrounging around
corners to find materials all while
avoiding packs of enemies looking to
pummel you while there's still plenty of
mind-bending in perspective skewing set
pieces the explorable spaces are the
real standout in many ways is like
traversing through a demented amusement
park filled with hideous creations
forcing yourself to face past horrors
[Music]
[Music]
if venturing to places not marked on the
map often yields valuable resources
leading to surprising encounters with
obsessive ghosts and multiple unnerving
fourth-wall breaking events
that's me from back then there's a clear
respect for the horror genre in the
within tube with its many references to
classic films and games the game
channels that same style and tone into
combat that feels brutal and raw stealth
that has an air of suspense and
confrontations with dangerous creatures
that are unsettling though there's some
occasional technical hiccups that result
in some particularly frustrating moments
and some weird pacing issues this horror
sequel elevates the tense and impactful
survival horror experience in ways that
feel fresh and exciting
[Music]
the evil within to doubles down on the
core of what makes survival horror
titles so great which is the focus on
disempowerment and obstacles and the
ensuing satisfaction that comes from
surviving the assault while what the
cerebral horror game does isn't totally
new it doesn't in a way that feels fresh
and engaging coming in at a lengthy and
surprisingly packed 15 hour campaign the
sequel does an admirable job of
ratcheting up the tension and the scares
when it needs to while also giving you
the freedom to explore and proceed how
you want it's a tough thing to balance
but the evil within to does it
remarkably well and in a way that leaves
a strong and lasting impression after
its touching conclusion you look tired
detective I can help you get back in
shape
just like before
[Music]